man I'll promise she's subconscious
doing it cause Kanye West takes his
Sunday service to Coachella
[Music]
the singer kicked off Sunday's events at
week two of the Music Festival in Indio
California with a religious Easter
experience and is famous family in tow
say Happy Easter
you look so pretty guys Chlo to Smurf
wife Kim Kardashian took your Instagram
stories to document the occasion and
everyone's color coordinated outfits are
us West who is performing at Sunday's
service matching outfits with mom check
out this adorable moment showing
daughter North playing with her cousin
Penelope Disick this is stormy true and
shy in a few years as for Kanye's
Coachella service
the two and a half hour long performance
featured a full band and choir wearing
matching pink baggy shirts and pants
while performing a medley of gospel
songs mixed with a few of Kanye's hits
like all falls down and power
Kanye spent most of the performance
wandering around and occasionally
hitting the keyboard only singing three
songs in total including a new song
called water at one point cameras even
caught the rapper crying chance the
rapper made a guest appearance so did
DMX who delivered a powerful message the
service came to an end with Kanye
falling to his knees after singing jesus
walks seemingly taking a moment to pray
for the past few months West has been
putting on an invite-only Sunday service
every week complete with a full-on
gospel choir his famous family and
celebrity guests
[Music]